صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي تنوي استراليا
الحصول عليها دخلت مرحله هندسه اللمسات
الاخيره هذه الصفقه تقدر بحوالي 37 مليار
دولار
وستشتري بموجبها استراليا نحو اربع غواصات
امريكيه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه من طراز
فيرجينيا او وسط فيرجينيا التي يستبعد
تسليمها قبل ثلاثينيات القرن الحالي هي
احدث غواصه هجوميه سريعه في البحريه
الامريكيه تملك القدره على استخدام اسلحه
مختلفه بما فيها التوربيدات وصواريخ كروز
وتنفذ مهام استخباراتيه واستطلاعيه صفقات
الغواصات تاتي بموجب تحالف اوكوس الثلاثي
الذي اعلن عنه عام 2021 بين كل من
استراليا والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ويهدف طبعا الى المواجهه ومواجهه الوجود
العسكري المتنامي للصين وتحديدا في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وشكلت هذه الصفقه
موضوع خلاف حاد حيدها بين استراليا وفرنسا
فالاخيره كما نذكر اقصيت من هذا المشروع
بعد ضغوط امريكيه واستراليا طبعا عوضت
شركه نافال الفرنسيه بخمس مئه وخمسه
وخمسين مليون دولار
[موسيقى]